From science and technology, here's what's new.
Nintendo has released Pokemon Go in Australia, New Zealand and the US...
...and in one day, it became one of the most downloaded apps ever.
Using something called augmented reality,...
...Pokemon Go merges the classic nineties video game with the real world...
...by accessing your smartphone's GPS, clock and camera,...
...making it possible for Pokemon characters to appear...
...in your house, neighborhood or anywhere in real time.
Hordes of players, heads down, eyes fixed on their phones,...
...are hunting for a Pokemon as we speak.
So many people have downloaded the app,...
...Nintendo says some of their servers are crashing,...
...delaying the international rollout of the app.
Pokemon Go players are being warned of thieves luring other players...
...to remote game locations to rob them.
Pokemon Go is a free app.
Nintendo makes its money from in-game purchases.
For VOA's What's New, I'm Todd Grosshans.